what's wrong with mRNA technology the
main thing is that because we haven't
used it on a mass scale before there's
lots of things we don't know about it so
what's actually happening with these
vaccines is you inject it now what's
supposed to happen is it supposed to
stay in your arm but what we now know is
happening they're actually being
systemically absorbed suppose that that
mRNA lipid nanoparticle is going through
a blood vessel in your heart for example
and because the lipid nanoparticle has
got a fatty wall and the cells in your
heart have got a fatty wall they will
absorb into each other and that would
let the MRNA into the cells now but not
in your arm now could be in your heart
then the immune system will come by and
say oh on this heart cell there's a bit
of a foreign material that's not
supposed to be there and so what it does
is it mounts an immunological reaction
to that foreign Spike protein but it
happens to be in the heart and if you
get inflammation in the heart muscle
that's called myocarditis we don't we
don't want these things